The problem with church is the problem with anybody that gets in any sort of a
position of power,
it's easy to abuse it.
So the have a guy who's a pastor that's not a creep and that really cares and is
really a good person and really wants to care about the community and really
rise once everybody to do better and get better with life but isn't trying to
buy a fucking Rolls Royce like Joel Olsteen and live in a giant mansion.
It's like,
and it always go church and always goes.
It always goes south.
It's absolutely love about Joel Olsteen is,
he's an arena act as a preacher.
He's um,
he bought the old place,
the old arena where the uh,
the Houston Rockets used to play.
He bought it.
Yeah.
That's how much money that guy has.
And then he fills it up.
Yeah.
Well that was when the hurricane came.
People criticized him cause he didn't open up its doors to a,
all the folks who were displaced from their homes tease them about that.
It's like you saw that electric blue carpet he put on anything.
What do Yo,
you fucking guys getting it all wet?
No,
he does.
He has his sick as we look at that place.
Oh,
maybe it's the curtain that I thought.
Yeah.
I mean look at that fucking place.
Holy Shit that looks like a dice clay special and all those people is thrown
down.
All those people are paying to be there.
Okay.
There's somebody out there,
scalping tickets.
I got to buy the altar is two ways of looking at it,
right?
One is these getting all those people together and there's a sense of community
amongst all of them.
And two is that guys making out fuck load of money and he's got so much power.
You know,
you and all those people just at your,
but it doesn't mean you're necessarily a bad,
nick doesn't necessarily mean he's like,
what?
What can you do with it?
Which is getting the reason why I'm thinking,
uh,
you know,
stopping in every once in a while,
uh,
got to find a good spot.
Like they were doing that rock and roll church thing for a while.
There was,
uh,
I remember,
one of my friends who's a producer,
his assistant was,
she was lost.
She,
I think she want to spiritually or she was lost a lot of ways,
but she,
uh,
was doing this,
what's going on Jamie?
Get through 4,000,
$950 for the author to,
do you want to go?
What the fuck?
Yeah,
we could do that.
1,000.
It's 400 bucks.
No,
no,
no.
$4,950.
Two tickets for two tickets.
Right.
Sanction for ro Rodeo de Dude for grand.
And what that guy fucking,
that's not even at the state.
Catch the handkerchief when he's done fucking preaching how much I get for a
row.
Two or so they're not available.
Not available.
So now he's a resale tickets to them.
Know what it is,
man.
They got fucking season passes.
People probably buy season passes to Joel Olsteen says this to her.
This is her,
this Florida stop.
Well,
I saw there was a place,
uh,
that I was at that he was coming to and one of the,
one of the big spots I was at,
he does these arena tours and he does a Vegas too.
He does the fucking t mobile arena in Vegas.
I want to see the show picture of him up there and his eyes open,
smiling and shit.
It's crazy.
It's a lot of money that guys make.
I used to say he's so full of,
he can't look at the crowd.
That's why his eyes are still here.
They still believe in this shit
there.
When you lie in eye contact is the toughest fucking thing ever.
But whatever he's making people feel good.
He's making his fuck.
He's in show business.
I want to see the show though.
He's in the God showbiz.
New happens.
You have to respect an arena act I think.
I think there's something to that.
There's something to do that.
It's
this girl that was talking about,
she was real lost and I think she was Jewish or maybe she converted to Judaism
later.
But anyway,
for one point in time she was going to this rock and roll church.
She was like,
she was a sweet kid.
you should go.
You would really like it.
I'm like,
I guarantee you wouldn't like it.
wait,
some young hip guy probably sing songs,
probably tries to fuck women.
Like get Outta here with that.
It's like a yoga class.
It's like David Koresh.
Waco got started.
How did it get started?
And get started with one guy with a guitar and he brought that message of Jesus
and he had some really profound things to say and people really,
it really helped them feel better,
resonated with them.
Then he started banging people's wives and that's what happens.
Yeah.
It always happens that way.
Well,
those rock and roll alternative churches,
there's a few of the,
like the Justin Bieber Guy,
you know the guy that uh,
Justin Bieber has,
he's the one who told Justin to get off the road,
cut off,
throw Justin,
come back home to Jesus like he's getting,
he gets these guys to do like,
get a basketball player.
Stop playing basketball to not apply,
but no,
no,
no.
That,
that guy's not doing the road anymore.
Oh,
he goes back and forth.
I mean,
it took a little time off at the end of this tour.
Canceled his tour because,
uh,
the,
the preacher told them it's,
well,
maybe he's right though.
Let's be honest.
First of all,
beeper,
probably as a fucking billion dollars in the bank.
And maybe he was frayed around the edges is losing his fucking marbles.
The kid's 21 years old.
He's about as famous as a human being.
Could possibly he only 21 shy.
He's young.
There's the preacher.
Whoa,
whoa,
whoa.
What the fucking Dick groat preach.
Hold up.
See what seats,
what's going on with his fucking shorts brow.
No,
no,
no.
Any guy who show and Dick Route.
You know what I mean?
Like the base of your cock,
you're pulling your shorts down to base your cock like that.
You're doing that because you're trying to get laid.
Stop.
Pull your fucking shorts up to a normal height.
Those things should be five inches higher.
I know what you're doing.
Your cock is slapping against your thing.
You probably don't even have underwear on you fucking creep.
Jesus does not want you dressing like that.
No.
And look at them.
It's kind of habs big old handsome guy.
He probably Dick's chicks down for the Lord,
right?
Dick's.
Dick's some down for Jesus.
It's really them.
Big Old,
handsome,
charismatic guy taking him down for Jesus.
Apparently he's a very,
he's a host.
Get to Yangon.
Would Oprah.
So you know he's legit.